thousands were there to receive
king abdullah of jordan on his return
from a state visit to washington
he cut short his trip after the news
came out that a jordanian pilot had been
murdered by islamic state
jordan is a key player in the u.s led
coalition against the jihadist group
in egypt the arab league condemned the
pilot's killing as a barbaric
the act world is sorry that there's an
organization or rather a criminal
operation like this in the region
all our condolences go to jordan and
it's king
two iraqi terrorists were executed at
this jail south of oman
early on tuesday morning but for the
father of the murdered pilot
this is not enough
i want the state to get revenge for my
son's blood through more executions of
those who follow this criminal group
his son also vowed to avenge his
brother's death
and called for jordanians to unite
we live in jordan we will protect jordan
and die in jordan
god willing the army will take revenge
for muaf falca
jordan's king has promised a harsh
response